zero and liftoff of the Delta rocket
with opportunity a chance to explore and
unlock the secrets of our neighboring
planet when the rover Opportunity lifted
off a border Delta rocket in 2003 no one
dreamed it would be more than 15 years
later that they finally say goodbye
within days of touching down on the Red
Planet opportunity was sending back
pictures from the Martian surface and
providing some answers to that big
question whether there was ever enough
water to support life there we have
concluded that the rocks here were once
soaked in liquid water still opportunity
wasn't done ploughing on across Mars
exploring the craters on its surface and
only falling silent eight months ago an
intense dust storm blocking the sunlight
from its solar panels the messages from
Mission Control went unanswered there's
an emotional time nASA has finally given
up opportunity for dead you know when
this little rover landed the objective
was to have it be able to move 1,100
yards and survive for 90 days on Mars
ninety Souls and instead here we are 14
years later after 28 miles of travel and
today we get to celebrate the end of
this mission and liftoff
we're Rovers like opportunity led others
will now follow space agencies in Europe
Russia China the Middle East are all
planning Mars missions and others have
more ambitious ideas Elon Musk in his
SpaceX engineers want to send a rocket
with a human crew to Mars by 2024 with
the aim of establishing a
self-sustaining civilization they're not
to be outdone Donald Trump has offered
NASA unlimited funds to put humans on
Mars however much any of that is
possible we'll be down to the work of
Rovers like opportunity and if there's
sadness among the scientists there's
also gratitude and recognition that
Earth's longest-serving ambassador to
Mars
answered the biggest question of all
Gregg Milam Sky News Los Angeles